let's consider another example of
continuous mass transfer suppose we have
a truck and that truck has some type of
plow and it's plowing snow and there's
some type of external force acting on
this truck
friction pushing the truck forward so
let's just assume we have some type of
force F on the truck and this is our
snow and what's happening in this
problem is that the truck connects picks
up the snow and then which is at rest
initially gets the snow up to the speed
of the truck and then the snow falls off
the plow so how do we model this problem
well let's look at our situation at time
T and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
consider a certain mass of snow Delta M
s that's at rest in our truck with a
fixed mass truck is moving with the
velocity V T at time T the truck so now
what happens at time T plus delta T well
the truck has picked up the mass of the
snow and the truck has now changed its
speed so that's at time T plus delta-t
and now we want to write down our
momentum law so we have our external
force let's call this the plus I hat
direction we have our external force is
equal to the limit as delta T goes to
zero of the momentum at time T so we
have T plus delta T so what we have is
the mass of the truck plus Delta M s
times V of T plus delta T and we have to
subtract for that's divided by delta T
and we have subtract from this the
momentum at time T the snow is at rest
only the truck is moving so we have
minus T
the T divided by delta T now as usual
we're gonna say that the truck has
changed its velocity in this interval
and what we want to do now is write out
our equation we have F equals the limit
as delta T goes to 0 of now when we
write this out notice that we're gonna
have a number of terms here we have em T
plus Delta M s times V Plus Delta V the
truck that's the first term divided by
delta T and the second term is just
minus mass of the truck of T over delta
T well first off we see some
cancellations between this term this and
that and what we're left with is limit
as delta T goes to 0 of we have the snow
term Delta M s over delta T times V
truck now here we have a term which
we're gonna analyze in a moment it has
two infinitesimal quantities and this
term is of second-order which we're
going to neglect and finally we have the
term of mass of the truck times Delta V
T delta T so neglecting the second-order
it term in differentials what we get
when we take the limit is that we get
the force is d the rate that the snow is
being picked up times V at the truck
plus mass of the truck times B truck DT
now the only issue that we have to think
about here is about the rate that the
truck the snow is being picked up so
that's our last consideration but this
will be our differential equation for
adding mass continually to a system so
when we found our equation for
describing the rate that the truck
changes its
beed the snowplow when it's pushing snow
away let's we wrote down our equation in
terms of the external force on the truck
the rate that snow is being picked up by
the truck the velocity of the truck mass
of the truck the rate of change of
velocity of the truck if we multiply our
equation through by DT we have the
following equation and now what we want
to consider is we want to focus on how
much DM s is picked up in our in our
infinitesimal time GT so one way to
think about that is let's do a little
drawing so here's our truck and let's
say at time T the plow is right here so
here's the picture at time T now let's
draw some snow here here in New England
we have lots of snow and at time T plus
delta-t the truck has moved a certain
distance
and so this quantity is the amount of
snow that's picked up by the truck and
displaced now the truck has moved a
distance V truck delta T and so we can
identify the delta ms which in the limit
will be DMS is equal to the density of
snow times the cross sectional area of
the plow times the length veve truck
delta T and so now we have an expression
for the rate that the mass is being
picked up in this time interval and we
can write that in the following way that
we see that our differential equation F
DT equals DMS which is Rho a BT times DT
this will be small interval we're taking
a limit now times another VT plus MT DB
T now we can bring this term over to the
other side and so we have F minus Rho a
BT squared times DT equals mass of the
truck times DV DT and the mass of the
truck in this case is fixed why because
when the snow gets into the truck at the
end of this delta T time interval it
gets displaced to the side so this is an
equation that we can separate and
integrate so we have DT is equal to M T
divided by F minus Rho a BT squared
DB T and we integrate from some initial
time there's some final time and here
we're integrating from V of truck from
some t initial time to some final time
and
that's our integral version for our
finding the velocity this integral is an
integral that's not hard to do that you
should try as an exercise in elementary
calculus